imagine that you're a member of Congress
you've worked very hard you've knocked
on thousands of doors sweating and
shivering depending on the season you've
made hundreds maybe thousands of phone
calls to people you don't even know
asking for their support begging for
their money and now you got one of these
it's hanging on a door in Washington DC
it says you're a member of Congress that
you represent the people of your state
now imagine you're a conservative member
of Congress for some of you here in
Boston Massachusetts that's gonna take a
powerful imagination all right
but imagine with me that you're a
conservative member of Congress you grew
up on Milton Friedman you love his free
markets free enterprise and free trade
you've watched Ronald Reagan's farewell
address over and over and you cry every
time he gets to the part about the
shining city on the hill and how if the
city had to have walls the walls had
doors doors to let in though his burning
to breathe free you get goosebumps when
you think of him telling mr. Gorbachev
to tear down his wall you're a
conservative member of Congress and you
agree with President John F Kennedy that
America is an exceptional place for
inspiration you go to youtube and you
watch his speech at Rice University
September of 1962 the moonshot speech
and you're amazed that he admits in that
speech a speech of 17 minutes of pure
American exceptionalism
that some of the materials needed for
the spacecraft hadn't been invented yet
no matter we're going to the moon before
the decade is out you agree with him
that the vowels of this nation can be
fulfilled only if we in this nation are
first and therefore we intend to be
first
you've taken as your own the effect that
he's so embodied that when leaders are
optimistic they're saying they believe
in the people they represent you're a
conservative member of Congress and you
believe in the precautionary principle
you believe in data-driven analysis you
know that climate change is real and
human caused and you see in climate
change a sly a silent and slow-moving
Sputnik moment one that calls for the
greatness of your nation as much as the
original Sputnik moment you're a
conservative member of Congress you
high-five the memory of Jack Kent and
believe with him that the test of
conservatism is that it works for
everyone regardless of skin color you're
appalled by the alt-right
you want them to have nothing to do with
your brand your party your legacy you
utterly reject them you
you are a conservative member of
Congress you rise with compassion to
protect the lives of the unborn but
otherwise you think the bedroom of
consenting adults is a rather strange
place for the government to be you are a
Conservative member of Congress with
John Adams you fear the mob because you
know as he knew that a mob is not able
to protect liberty not even its own and
you're amazed at the wisdom that he and
other framers had in establishing a slow
deliberative governing process and
inherently gut a conservative governing
process they would serve a country that
would grow far greater than they could
ever imagine you are conservative member
of Congress you fear the fire of
populist nationalism because you know
that those who play with fire can't
control it you see their pitchforks and
torches and you know they're not good
building tools that pitchforks and
torches can tear down and burn up but
they can't build up they can't build up
the institutions and the communities so
necessary to a stable and prosperous
country you're a conservative member of
Congress and you fear the next County
Party convention you so wish for your
party to be the grand opportunity party
not the grumpy old party you know that
they want to hear from you some old saw
about how a secret Muslim non American
socialist took over in the White House
and destroyed the country and you know
that none of that's true
you know that they want to hear you say
that you're okay with insults okay with
lock her up chance and okay with policy
pronouncements with all the sincerity
and thoughtfulness that 140 characters
can muster you are a conservative member
of Congress you realize it many in your
party look to some good old days that
you know never existed they hold on for
example to the fossils that fueled the
last century of growth but you know that
better cleaner more abundant fuels await
us and you know that that abundance can
lead the world to more energy more
mobility and more freedom you're a
conservative member of Congress you
realize that many in your party pine for
the 50s and the 60s because those were
after all the good old days but you know
that the Cuyahoga River was on fire
back then you know that in Pittsburgh
streetlights came on at noon because of
the soot in the air the schools were
segregated neighborhoods redlined that
communism threatened freedom and if you
got cancer you weren't likely to fight
for long you're a conservative member of
Congress and you want to sound like JFK
that rice where JFK said it's
understandable by what some would have a
stay where we are a little bit longer to
wait and to rest but everything within
you says with him this city of Houston
this state of Texas this country of the
United States was not built by those who
waited and rested and wished to look
behind them you are ready to lead you
are ready to prove the power of free
enterprise to solve challenges like
climate change
you are ready to lead so I've got a
suggestion for you then lead now step
out step up you know we asked America's
best to die on littoral Hills in places
like Iraq and Afghanistan is it too much
to ask you to die a figurative death on
a political hill in Washington DC you
know at the end of your time in
Washington they going to take this
plaque off the door they're gonna hand
it to you if you're gonna go home with
it
can you imagine the emptiness of knowing
that you stood for nothing that you risk
nothing that all you did was follow
fearful people to where they were
already going rather than trying to lead
them to a better place if you're not
willing to lose your seat in Congress
there's really very little reason to be
there
so here's the thing it's not too late
there's still time to lead speak out
speak up
call lunacy what it is lunacy tell the
American people that we still have
moonshots in us tell the folks at the
county party convention you bet free
enterprise can solve climate change tell
them that Milton Friedman would say to
tax pollution rather than profits tell
them that it's okay
no it's a good thing that progressives
would agree
tell them the very good news that we can
bring America together to solve these
challenges and to lead the world tell
them that free enterprise can do these
things tell them that America must stop
the dividing and must start the uniting
tell them play your part before it's too
late
thank you